all right tony congratulations you've
made it into the third level of this
multi-level competition now the judge
you're competing against
oh man abs master smith jay nielsen the
beast from the east you got your hands
full with this one all right have fun
jay welcome back you know how this goes
you guys have eight hours to do a custom
blade build and at the end of that we're
gonna award one of you a ten thousand
dollar prize
now
in this third level of competition we're
gonna be asking you guys to make short
swords they must measure between 20 and
22 inches in length they must have a
functional guard a mechanically attached
handle and a pummel that sounds easy
enough right
but you'll be making them out of these
saw blades
from these saw blades you must make a
canister damascus billet
but not any canister damascus billet a
no can canister damascus billy which
means that once you're done forge
welding your can you must peel off the
outer layer of mild steel and use only
the high carbon steel from inside your
cans to forge your blades all right
gents your eight hour starts
now
i'm gonna take the saw blades i'm gonna
stack them vertically but i'm gonna
leave about a 3 16 gap between each
blade so that i can fill it up with
10.95 and that's gonna be a cushion
i saw that bandsaw steel
so i figured hey great bandsaw blades
make hard steel
i've got these two uh billets in that
i've tacked together in the forge and
i'm waiting
i get the right color
and i set the weld
and then i start drawing out my billet
did i know that i was going to have
almost twice as much as i needed yes
but i'm thinking in my head
what if i have a little d limb
i can just cut that off draw back to the
length i need
and i'm golden
[Music]
[Music]
tony's in the quench
i pull it out
and yeah
it's hard
i think jay's going to go for a quench
jay just quench
all right jake quench i pulled the blade
out of the crunch it's straight i'm
happy
i'll check it that sounds good
and it sings like a bird blade smiths
you have just three hours remaining to
finish your work
you've got to keep moving you can't stop
so while the blade is in the tempering
oven i'm gonna get back working on the
handle and hardware
i pick the mild steel for the card and
pummel because i plan on blowing both of
them that's going to save me a little
time in doing a high finish on it
i'm getting all the hardware and handle
skills fit it up and then i'm going to
get everything profiled out so
everything fits right in tight i got
like 10 12 minutes left and i double
check
over and i'm like an eighth of an inch
over parameters uh-oh
if i turned a blade that was out of
parameters
i might as well just kick me off this
show
beautiful
five
four
three
two
one blade smith shut down your machines
drop your tools this level of
competition is over
good job on that man all right
bleedsmiths welcome to the keel test
now it's time to find out what kind of
lethal damage your short swords will do
to do that i will take your weapons and
deliver some lethal blows on this big
carcass tony up first you ready for this
absolutely
nice cuts man
i can tell it's heavy though
all right tony let's talk about your
sword here
it's a heavy beast yes it's about four
pounds on this requires more work to
wield multiple times
but overall it's a good chopper and
slasher and
it will keel
all right jay you're up next are you
ready do me a favor heal it
will do
i love the pig dust
tony's blade did great but uh
after 20 plus years of making knives i'd
better be confident going into this
[Music]
yes cuts
all right jay let's talk about your
short sword
first up what i like about this it's a
lighter sword you can wheel this
single-handedly and be able to do this
all day because of its weight
your handle construction is smooth
everything's rounded
and this is a sharp edge
it cuts deeply into this big carcass not
very deep because the weight is not on
the sword i can wield it and cut
accordingly more importantly sir your
sword
you'll heal
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test the pot shop
now this test is all about what those
pots can do to the edge of your blades
tony you're up first you ready for this
yes i am
[Music]
didn't break nice
all right so tony
everything's solid still together
perfectly you've lost a little bit of
edge right through here just sort of
packed out as opposed to chipped or
rolled
but it's a neat looking design um i
think you did a great job thank you
all right jay your turn you ready go for
it ben okay
no it didn't break yeah
all right so jay
i like the balance of your blade
uh it's forward but it's a light blade
so it's comfortable being up there uh
you lost
a little bit of edge again it's just
kind of compacted
blade's solid
did great feels good in the hand nice
and done
it's miss to check out how much of your
edge is still left on your blade so i'm
going to be chopping at these sandman
tony you're up first you're ready for
this don't hurt yourself
at this point the competition we're neck
and neck
and it's going to come down to the
sharpness test
well tony
there is a
sort of sweet spot to cut things and
this is where all of the damage from the
pots went
and the first cut is probably a little
further down into this sharp region and
it cut cleanly through the first arm but
when i came around to start hitting on
those hips and the thighs
it was just kind of bludgeoning the
sandman instead of really cutting in
nice and deeply
other than that it's a really
interesting design
man this is a heavy heavy sword
all in all
it'll cut some stuff okay
all right jay you're up next you ready
all right nonverbal communication
[Laughter]
wow
[Music]
all sucked
all right jay
i love the weight of this weapon i think
it's perfectly balanced and the weight
is just a joy to swing
it didn't cut very well on a lot of the
strikes did about halfway through on the
wrist and then mostly just scratches on
the body
all in all i think you made a light fast
fun weapon
so nice job
all right gents the judge's deliberation
is complete
they've made their final decision the
winner of this beat the judge's
competition is
jay nielsen
congratulations ten thousand dollars
will be donated to the charity of your
choice what charity is that melanoma
foundation all right that is an
excellent excellent foundation tony
unfortunately your blade didn't make the
cut this time
tony this came down to a matter of
weight that short sword weighs more than
really a two-hander should so right it
did the job but that weight is just
extreme okay
donnie yeah hey good job good job man
yeah are you gonna hug was that i was
gonna hug like that was an awkward
moment we're two
all
yeah tony is a great competitor he did a
great piece but you know i squeaked
ahead of him
got ten thousand dollars going to
melanoma foundation i feel good
this time i didn't beat the judge you
know it never feels good to not win when
you really go bust ass but i've learned
a lot don't make your blades too heavy
good job jay but watch out for next time
i'm coming back
[Music]
you